women want men that just get it that are
competent that can solve problems that
can get things done that they don't want
to deal with a crybaby as soon as you
start stamping everything yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes and then you
give her the stamp and she starts
stamping everything yes her interest in
that guy declines dramatically like
don't you want a girl to contest with
every that around again don't you want a
little bit of a challenge there's a
perfect ratio of disagreements that need
to happen in a relationship and that's
right you know I don't know what your
thoughts are in Jordan Peterson but
he'll talk about that too you don't want
it easy you want some level of challenge
that is required for the relationship to
be strong you don't want to push over do
you do you I'm a super girl I I don't
want to come home to a disagreeable
bossy woman
I want to come home to a loving woman